[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings where we're
bringing you part two of our cbs news
investigation into the california
medical board we sat down for an
exclusive interview with an insider who
says the system is costing patients
their lives yesterday you may recall we
introduced you to two patients who said
they were hurt by a doctor who has
already been under investigation by the
board and was nonetheless allowed to
continue practicing it's a perplexing
case our chief investigative
correspondent jim axelrod has been
digging into it perplexing and
concerning yeah good morning tony that
you know the stated mission of the
california medical board is to quote
protect health care consumers but our
cbs news investigative team found that
doctors who repeatedly hurt their
patients are often allowed to continue
practicing today we hear from two men
who say the system is broken and efforts
to reform it have failed for years
i'm speaking out because i can't sleep
at night
tj watkins was appointed to the
california medical board in 2019.
you
can't sleep at night because the way the
board does its business yes
watkins previously served as vice
president of the california board that
licenses physical therapists he's
speaking out now because he's troubled
by what he's seen on the medical board
the way they speak is always with doctor
care in mind
you never hear patient care ever
and i mean ever
do you think the way
the medical board functions in the state
of california
actually ends up costing patient lives
there's no question that it cost
patients lives watkins started tracking
discipline cases and says the california
medical board handed out more lenient
punishments than its guidelines
suggested in nine out of every 10 cases
so in ninety percent of the cases that
crossed my desk in the year 2020
we did not follow the guidelines cbs
news analyzed the last five years of
disciplinary decisions made by the
medical board which works hand in hand
with the attorney general's office
the board sanctioned more than 200
doctors for repeated acts of gross
negligence but allowed them to continue
practicing are you surprised at all
no
not at all because i'm in the room
i'm in the room trying to stop that from
happening
for the last year
watkins has been fighting to force the
board to hold doctors accountable the
process is not working for the public
but unfortunately it's working perfectly
perfectly for the doctors
one physician member on the board
chastised watkins last month for rocking
the boat in my eight years on this board
i have not encountered another board
member
who has been so
negative about our process as mr watkins
while the mission of the 15-member
california medical board is to quote
protect healthcare consumers
two of the 15 seats are occupied by
former presidents of the california
medical association which lobbies
lawmakers from its headquarters here in
sacramento on behalf of nearly 50 000
doctors in the state
did you ever run into an opponent as
fierce as the california medical
association no
never did
few know more about the california
medical association or the cma and its
lobbying power than jerry hill
their ability to
bring money to the table
to bring support
all factors into their ability to
control the medical board and control
legislation going forward
the former state senator chaired the
committee that oversees the board and
spent years of his political career
trying to make the medical board more
accountable today i introduced the
patient right to know act of 2018. the
cma
in your view
is it a powerful organization probably
one of the most powerful special
interests that we have here they are
masters at
getting what they want from any
legislation we analyzed the california
medical association's political
contributions and found that since 2015
they've spent nearly 15 million dollars
on lobbying and in donations to state
candidates
and during governor newsome's recall
election cma gave seven hundred fifty
thousand dollars to the california
democratic party
governor newsom's office declined to
comment the medical board said the law
requires it to rehabilitate doctors when
possible and told us that no matter what
the board follows its mission which is
to protect patients
as for the california medical
association they declined an interview
request but pointed out that it has
fought for public health during covet
and pushed for regulations that quote
protect patients from bad doctors
oh boy what's there at the end about the
california medical association but i
want to go back to mr watkins for a
second i'm in awe of him a current board
member who's speaking out against the
board do you think it's going to hurt
his standing on the board you know i
asked tj
what are you doing like you know what
what are you doing why all right what
are the consequences here and and he
grew up in south africa during apartheid
and it was very clear he said look and
he he his philosophy is
uh that you know in his words were evil
to triumph good men do nothing so to be
a good man yes in his view he had to
stand up and talk to us and that's what
that was all about for clarification
we're not talking about small botched
procedures like sometimes
these come to fatal endings for these
patients yes and then the investigations
in sue and
people these doctors continue to
practice absolutely
if i'm a patient this morning i'm not
feeling great in california knowing that
my board that's supposed to protect me
as lobbyists and doctors on it the right
millions of reasons why this system will
continue as you saw at the end yeah i
think that might change though thank you
mr watkins who said he couldn't sleep at
night thank you jim axelrod